♪ ♪
>> Sean: AS WE CONTINUE OUR
EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES,
MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL,
PRESIDENT COMMENT IN, YOU ARE
VERY CLEAR.
LET ME FIRST SAY, YOU HAVE THE
PATIENCE OF JOB ON STEROIDS AND
HUMAN GROWTH HORMONE WHEN YOU
WENT BEFORE THE CLOWN SHOW IN
CONGRESS, GOD BLESS YOU FOR IT
BECAUSE I DON’T THINK I HAVE THE
PATIENCE YOU DO AND IT WAS
REALLY PRETTY DESPICABLE TO ME.
THE PRESIDENT WEIGHED IN ON
DURHAM, YOU ARE PRETTY CLEAR IN
YOUR TESTIMONY, YOU ARE
INDEPENDENT.
PRESIDENT SAID TODAY THAT HE
HOPES THE DURHAM REPORT AND THAT
U.S. ATTORNEY GENERAL WON’T BE
POLITICALLY CORRECT.
I HOPE THAT, TOO.
I SPENT THREE YEARS ON PEELING
THE LAYERS OF AN ONION.
PREMEDITATED FRAUD ON THE FISA
COURT.
YOU HAVE THE DELETED SUBPOENA
EMAILS, THE KNOWLEDGE WE KNOW
THEY WERE WARNED IN AUGUST OF
2016 NOT TO TRUST THAT DOSSIER
WHICH IS THE BULK OF INFORMATION
FROM THE PFIZER WARRANTS, THE
SUB SOURCE IN JANUARY 2017
CONFIRMS NONE OF THAT WAS TRUE,
JUSTICE TURN SLOWLY I FEEL
IMPATIENT OVER IT, CAN YOU GIVE
US ANY UPDATE?
>> YES, SEAN.
FIRST, AS TO THE POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS, IF I WAS WORRIED
ABOUT BEING POLITICALLY CORRECT
I WOULDN’T HAVE JOINED THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Sean: THAT’S ACTUALLY A
GOOD LINE, TOO.
>> AS I MADE CLEAR, I’M GOING TO
CALL THEM AS I SEE THEM.
I THINK I’M IN A POSITION TO DO
THAT.
TWO DIFFERENT THINGS GOING ON.
I SAID THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED
TO KNOW WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED,
WE NEED TO GET THROUGH THE STORY
OF WHAT HAPPENED IN 2016 AND IF
I FASTER B-17 OUT.
OUTCOME OF THAT WILL BE DONE.
THE SECOND ASPECT OF THIS IS IF
PEOPLE CROSS THE LINE, PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THAT ACTIVITY
VIOLATED CRIMINAL LAW, THEY WILL
BE CHARGED.
AND JOHN DURHAM IS AN
INDEPENDENT MAN, HIGHLY
EXPERIENCED AND HIS
INVESTIGATION IS PURSUING A
PACE, THERE WAS SOME DELAY
BECAUSE OF COVID BUT I’M
SATISFIED WITH THE PROGRESS AND
I’VE SAID THERE ARE GOING TO BE
DEVELOPMENTS, SIGNIFICANT
DEVELOPMENTS FOR THE ELECTION
BUT WE ARE NOT DOING THIS ON THE
ELECTION SCHEDULE.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO DO ANYTHING
INAPPROPRIATE BEFORE THE
ELECTION BUT WE ARE NOT BEING
DICTATED TO BY THE SCHEDULE,
WHAT’S DICTATING THE TIMING OF
THIS OUR DEVELOPMENT OF THE CASE
AND THERE WILL BE DEVELOPMENTS
IS TOMORROW THERE WILL BE A
DEVELOPMENT IN THE CASE, IT’S
NOT AN EARTH SHATTERING
DEVELOPMENT BUT IT IS AN
INDICATION THAT THINGS ARE
MOVING ALONG AT THE PROPER PACE
AS DICTATED BY THE FACTS IN THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL,
YOU ONCE SAID THIS ISN’T ABOUT A
REPORT, THIS IS A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
YOU WERE VERY CLEAR THAT THE
SPY, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WAS SPIED ON DEEP
INTO HIS PRESIDENCY, YOU SAID.
NOW BASED ON WHAT WE KNOW AND
ANDREW McCABE SAID IT, SALLY
YATES SAID IT, ROD ROSENSTEIN
AND SALLY YATES WOULD NOT SIGN
THOSE WARRANTS TODAY, WE KNOW
THE FBI KNEW BEYOND ANY DOUBT
THAT IT NOT ONLY WAS THAT
DOSSIER, WITHOUT THE DOSSIER
THEY BOTH SAY THERE IS NO FISA
MORTGAGE.
THEY KNEW IT WAS FALSE, THEY
WERE TOLD IT WAS FALLS, THE LAW
REQUIRES THEM TO GO BACK TO THE
FISA COURT.
I JUST SEE PREMEDITATED FRAUD
AGAINST THE COURT AND I WOULDN’T
EVEN LIE BEFORE JUDGE JUDY,
MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL, I THINK
THEY THROW AWAY THE KEY IN MY
CASE.
>> WHEN WE FEEL WE CAN PROVE A
CRIME BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT
IT WILL BE CHARGE, I CAN TELL
YOU THAT.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
MAIL IN VOTING, I PAY VERY CLOSE
ATTENTION TO YOUR INTERVIEW WITH
MARK AND THOSE THAT WANT TO
EXPERIMENT WITH DIFFERENT WAYS
OF VOTING, THEY WANT TO DO THIS
NOW WITH 82 DAYS TO DO GO BEFORE
THE ELECTION.
I DON’T HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
GOVERNMENT TO FULFILL MANY
PROMISES THAT ALL, DOESN’T IT
LEND ITSELF TO GREAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR FRAUD?
>> YES, I THINK IT IS GROSSLY
IRRESPONSIBLE TO BE DOING WHAT
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS DOING
NOW.
WE’VE HAD VERY CLOSE RACES IN
RECENT HISTORY, THE COUNTRY IS
DIVIDED.
IF ANYTHING WE SHOULD BE
ASSURING THE INTEGRITY WITH OUR
ELECTIONS, SO THAT GOVERNMENT
GOING FORWARD WOULD BE
LEGITIMATE AND ACCEPTED AS
LEGITIMATE.
THE IDEA OF CONDUCTING ELECTIONS
BY WHOLESALE MAIL-IN BALLOTS IS
RECKLESS AND WRONG.
EVERYONE KNOWS WHAT IS HAPPENED
IN THESE CASES.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT VOTERS
GOING, REQUESTING A BALLOT
SPECIFICALLY, SAYING WHO THEY
ARE, PROVING WHO THEY ARE AND
SUBMITTING A BALLOT BY MAIL.
WE ARE TALKING, MAIL OUTS TO
EVERYONE ON THE VOTING LIST AND
EVERY EXPERIENCE WITH THAT HAS
HAD THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
BALLOTS FLOATING AROUND.
I HAVE FRIENDS WHO HAVEN’T LIVED
IN CALIFORNIA IN 21 YEARS WHO
RECEIVED BALLOTS.
THERE ARE BALLOTS LEFT IN BOXES
AND APARTMENT BUILDINGS.
BALLOTS ARE FOR PEOPLE WHO USED
TO LIVE AT ADDRESSES ARE
DELIVERED TO THOSE ADDRESSES,
THEY CAN BE FILLED OUT BY
ANYBODY.
THIS IS RECKLESS AND IT COULD
CREATE SERIOUS QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE INTEGRITY OF THE ELECTION.
AND TO DO THIS WHEN THERE ARE
CLOSELY DIVIDED COUNTRY AS WE
ARE IS PLAYING WITH FIRE IN MY
VIEW.
>> Sean: MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL,
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE SEATTLE
POLICE CHIEF CARMEN BEST.
WHAT AN AMAZING EXAMPLE OF
SERVICE AND DEDICATION TO HER
COMMUNITY AND HOW THEY, SHE
LITERALLY HAD TO RESIGN BECAUSE
OF THIS DEFUND EFFORT AND SHE
WAS NOT GIVEN THE ABILITY TO USE
THE TRAINING THAT ALL POLICE
OFFICERS HAVE, KNOW HOW TO
DISPERSE CROWDS, IT’S USUALLY
TEARGAS, PEPPER SPRAY BUT
THEY’VE TAKEN THESE TOOLS AWAY
FROM OFFICERS.
I BELIEVE IT’S NOW CREATED A
VERY DANGEROUS SITUATION FOR ALL
OF THEM.
I DON’T THINK IT TAKES A LOT OF,
MIT OR HARD HARVARD DEGREE TO
FIGURE OUT THIS IS NOT GOING TO
END WELL FOR A LOT OF THESE
CITIES, WHAT YOU SAY TO THOSE
THAT ARE DEMONIZING THE POLICE,
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE GROUP BLACK
LIVES MATTER, THE GROUP ANTIFA
AND THOSE THAT BELIEVE,
JOE BIDEN, I WILL BRING INTO
POLITICS BUT SAY THEY BECOME THE
ENEMY, KAMALA HARRIS SAYS SHE’S
HAPPY WITH THE L.A.P.D.
DEFENDING THE POLICE, I DON’T
THINK THIS IS GOING TO END WELL,
SIR.
I THINK LIVES WILL BE LOST AS A
RESULT.
>> LIVES ARE BEING LOST IN
VIOLENT CRIME.
AND THE DEMONIZATION OF THE
POLICE.
CARMEN BEST AS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
HIGHLY COMPETENT, PROFESSIONAL,
AND DEDICATED POLICE
PROFESSIONALS WE HAVE IN THIS
COUNTRY, WE ARE BLESSED WITH
THAT THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY,
THEY ARE EXCELLENT AND SHE IS A
GREAT EXAMPLE OF IT AND WE
SHOULD BE SUPPORTING THEM AND
BEING A POLICE OFFICER IS THE
HARDEST JOB IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE ARE ASKING PEOPLE TO GO INTO
VERY DANGEROUS SITUATIONS, TO
HAVE JOBS THAT ARE TERRIBLY
WEARING ON THEM AS INDIVIDUALS
AND ON THEIR FAMILIES, TO GO
INTO POTENTIALLY DEADLY
SITUATIONS NOT KNOWING WHAT WILL
HAPPEN AND WE HAVE DATA CONTINUE
TO ATTRACT THE BEST PEOPLE INTO
THESE JOBS.
AND UNLESS WE SUPPORT THE POLICE
WE ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE A
POLICE FORCE.
THESE COMMUNITIES ARE NOT GOING
TO HAVE THE SAFETY.
A LOT OF THE LIBERALS WILL BUY
THEMSELVES OUT OF THAT, GO TO
RESORT TOWNS AND SO FORTH AND
ESCAPE THE CONSEQUENCES OF IT
BUT THE PEOPLE IN THE INNER
CITIES WON’T.
THEIR LIVES WILL BE DESTROYED,
THEIR OPPORTUNITY WILL BE, WON’T
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY THEY
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE COME OTHER
SCHOOLS WILL BE OVERRUN BY
GANGS, THAT’S NOT CARING ABOUT
BLACK LIVES.
AND PEOPLE TALK ABOUT IMPLICIT
RACISM OR SYSTEMIC RACISM.
THE RACISM IN THIS COUNTRY, LOOK
NO FURTHER THAN OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
THAT’S A RACIST SYSTEM.
MAINTAINED BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE
TEACHERS UNION, KEEPING
INNER-CITY KIDS IN FAILING
SCHOOLS INSTEAD OF PUTTING THE
RESOURCES AND IN THE HANDS OF TH
PARENTS TO CHOOSE THE SCHOOLS TO
SEND THEIR KIDS TO.
THAT’S EMPOWERING KIDS, GIVING
THEM A FUTURE.
>> Sean: EVERY CHILD, THEY ARE
OUR NATIONS NATIONAL TREASURE.
YOU DID TALK ABOUT THE POLITICAL
ENVIRONMENT AND AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE PEOPLE TRY TO IMPEACH
DONALD TRUMP FROM DAY ONE.
WE’VE NOW SEEN THE
CRIMINALIZATION OF POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES, FOR EXAMPLE THE IG
MADE REFERRALS ABOUT TOP
OFFICIALS IN THE FBI, NOTHING
HAPPENED, THERE WAS NO PREDON
RAVED WITH GUYS IN TACTICAL GEAR
NOR WERE THERE CNN CAMERAS.
THOSE GUYS HAVEN’T BEEN
ARRESTED.
I WORRY THAT AMERICA IS
DESCENDING INTO 2-TIER JUSTICE
SYSTEM, AM I WRONG?
>> I THINK IT’S THE RIGHT WORRY
AND THE REASON I CAME BACK INTO
GOVERNMENT, WE CAN’T LET IT
HAPPEN BUT HERE’S THE THING.
THE WAY OUT OF THE
POLITICIZATION AND CORRUPTION OF
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM WHERE IT’S
USED AS A POLITICAL WEAPON BY
ONE PARTY AGAINST ANOTHER IS NOT
TO DELIVER TIT-FOR-TAT, NOT TO
USE THE TACTICS OF THE OTHER
SIDE, IT’S TO PULL THE RULE OF
LAW, USE THE RIGHT STANDARD AND
THAT’S WHAT I’M TRYING TO DO.
ONE STANDARD FOR EVERYBODY.
>> Sean: I KNOW YOU CAN’T
SHARE A LOT, I SPENT THREE AND A
HALF YEARS, I THINK WE FOUND A
LOT OF TRUTH.
1%, I ALWAYS MAKE THE
DISTINCTION, NOT THE 99%.
OF CAREER LAW ENFORCEMENT
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES IN THE